imagine you make history for becoming
the first immature in 33 years to an
apga Tour event but you don't get the
over a million doll cash prize at the
end that's life right now for
20-year-old Nick Dunlap who can't accept
the $1.5 million cash prize because he's
too young Nick is still a sophomore in
college and according to the USGA rules
he can't receive money that's excess of
$1,000 so where does the money actually
go well had he entered the competition
as a professional he would have been
able to claim it since that wasn't the
case it goes to Christian outen Hout by
default who Nick beat to be crowned
Champion yikes Nick can still hold his
head up by still being one of two
players to win the US Junior and US
amateur